you know it's fine that there are some  Republicans saying it was wrong of trump  to meet with white nationalists white  supremacists whatever Nick Fuentes Milo  yiannopoulos and this Kanye West meeting  that's all fine right I mean it's easy  it's more difficult for them to denounce  the white supremacist elements within  their party and we're talking about  members of the house maybe members of  the Senate at the local level denounce  the elected officials that your voters  have put in office and then maybe I'll  respect you a little bit more it's very  easy to say oh particularly by the way a  weakened Trump was wrong to meet with  those people it's not worth very much  they might want you to think that  they're principled but they're really  not